Leonard double-teams knocked away by
klay Thompson curry ahead of the pack
the soul in pursuit and it goes for
Steph Curry now with 14 points they do a
good job of hanging around in spite of
adversity they battle they compete and
give themself great without doping
draymond Green gihan on that one Lowry
gets curry off the three-point line so
curry runs and bangs on the foul or
backs on the layup it's a one-point game
by Leonard 4 for 10 from the field he
has 16 points
niggath Allen wide open for three and
Golden State regains the lead siakam
gets up in the Thompson down low
draymond Green backs at home and nine
straight points there for Golden State
to start this third quarter timeout play
they lift everybody up high because no
one will come off Arkansas misses on the
three the Marcus Cousins calling for
feet inside to Thompson banks at home of
the left hand another good feed from
DeMarcus Cousins for his third assist
passing the basketball from that post
position good move
away from the ball by klay Thompson
cuttings
[Applause]
Thompson for three klay Thompson rattles
around he looks at the Toronto bench
nods his head and : state has thrown up
14 points already here in the third
Thompson again gets inside uses that
offhand beautifully and it's 16 straight
points DeMarcus Cousins has been great
coach you're right rebound taketh isla
dream on green backs at home what an
avalanche here for Golden State a
13-point lead draymond Green gets inside
layup is good
another one of those all-around
performances from draymond Green is
being aggressive on the offensive end
bad defense by Kawhi Leonard
draymond Green puts his head down gets
into the paint over the contestant hand
of Kyle Lowry a beautiful finger roll
finish the first thing they say what
makes it so hard to defendant is how
strong he is how strong his hands on
Murray throws it up when Andrew bumped
it just in what an absolute luxury
quarter that's already six turnovers
well curry with the catch and Ibaka
shows up a little bit on a stunt and if
you're going to help with Ibaka
whoever's Louis has got to pull over and
take away the LOB Alfonso McKinney nice
looking floater there this is their time
to make the run
look wide open for three get rid of all
of them I don't agree with Jeff at all
Bogut on another alley-oop this time a
beautiful feed from draymond Green
siakam gets way up into curry final
minute third quarter curry long
three-putts it is chef curry from way
downtown let's back up to ten